if you're anything like me then you've
spent a lot of time using youtube to
listen to video game music for years
listening to game music on services like
spotify was basically impossible and
while things have gotten better youtube
is still the best place to go if you
want to listen to your favorite game
soundtrack or it was until last week
when the biggest most important uploader
of video game music on the entire
internet got barry in over 3 000
copyright claims and deleted his channel
alright so before we give the video i
just want to remind you all to please
sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help okay so if
you've ever used youtube to listen to
video game music you probably recognize
this guy his channel was called gill the
center and for over a decade it was the
go-to place to listen to video game
music on youtube but now if you try to
go to his channel all you get is a
stupid monkey that's because last week
he shut down his channel after he
received 3
500 copyright blocks from nintendo in
two days now you might be thinking to
yourself how on earth do you get 3 500
copyright blocks in two days
well when you upload game music you
don't own to youtube it kind of makes
sense you've got albums with what 20 30
songs on them sometimes even more and
each song from those albums is its own
unique individual youtube video which
means each video gets its own copyright
block and it's not like this is the
first time this happened to gilda center
over the past few years he's posted
images of his email inbox whenever he
received copyright blocks from nintendo
just last month he got over 1 300 on
january 29th alone hell in 2013 nintendo
claimed 70 of his videos in one day now
obviously gilva center never owned any
of the music he was uploading and
nintendo was well within their rights to
take his videos down but i think the
reason so many people including myself
are really upset about his channel
disappearing is because it's a little
more complicated than that see i'm a
really big fan of video game soundtracks
yes i know i'm a nerd but i really do
think that there's a lot of great music
in video games that's honestly sometimes
really hard to listen to like back in
the day if i wanted to listen to route
209 the best song in pokemon history
legally the only way i could do that
would be to turn on my ds turn on
pokemon pearl and bike out to the part
of the map where that song plays that's
because for years most video games just
didn't release cd soundtracks in the
west some games got exclusive
soundtracks in japan but those were
really expensive to import
so anybody who liked video game music
had to turn to piracy back then we
downloaded mp3s from the internet used
itunes to stick them on our ipods in
middle school and i know i'm dating
myself here but the point is that i
don't have a dedicated mp3 player
anymore
no one does we all stream our music
these days so that form of piracy is
basically obsolete and for the most part
video game publishers have only very
recently started putting their
soundtracks onto services like spotify
it's amazing that so much stuff is there
but a lot of songs aren't specifically
songs owned by nintendo which is why for
basically as long as youtube has existed
there have been channels dedicated to
uploading video game music for those of
us who want to listen to our favorite
songs but don't have dedicated mp3
players anymore and don't want to pay 65
to import a cd box sec also what would i
even listen to a cd on these days i
haven't had a cd drive in my computer
since 2014. anyway my point is that
there are hundreds if not thousands of
channels on youtube dedicated to ripping
and uploading video game music
specifically nintendo music and
gilbasunner was by far the biggest
before he took his channel down gilba
center had 6400 uploads 1.5 billion
views and was doing around 19 million
views a month basically gilda center was
kind of huge
and now the original gilva center
channel is gone literally wiped off the
face of youtube i know that ultimately
there are a ton of other channels you
can go to to listen to video game music
including some of the very tracks that
got copyright blocked on gilvasunner's
channel but i think what the channel's
deletion represents is really important
like i said earlier there was this era
of youtube where it was just the wild
west everyone is uploading movies and tv
shows and music they didn't own and it
lived alongside home movies and reaction
videos like the weirdest internet
library over the years youtube decided
they wanted to make money so they
started to run ads and clamped down hard
on piracy and while i get it i think
what it's led to is kind of sad there is
no good convenient legal way to listen
to music from nintendo games right now
for years that was also true about music
from companies like square enix capcom
and sega but these days if you search
spotify you'll find plenty of the
greatest video game albums of all time
meanwhile if you search for nintendo
music all you get are crappy covers
youtube is the place to go if you want
to listen to nintendo's contributions to
this art form i know it sounds like i'm
standing here defending piracy but i
literally am the fact of the matter is
the community saw that nintendo wasn't
doing a good job of preserving their own
history so they took matters into their
own hands gilbert center said it best
himself back in 2019 if companies like
nintendo felt so entitled to block his
videos why not work on actually getting
those songs up somewhere people can
legally listen to them it should have
been clear to them that fans would be
interested based on how many views gilba
center was getting oh and while we're
talking about nintendo let's do a quick
aside there was a thread going around
last week of people speculating that the
nintendo that blocked gilda center's
videos might not have actually been
nintendo but instead was a troll
pretending to be them youtube has since
stepped in to confirm that it was
actually nintendo that put out the
thousands of claims on gilbert center's
channel and i wanted to bring this up
because one it's important to clear the
air so everyone knows what's actually
going on here but also because two this
is absurd this is one of the biggest
gaming companies in the world going
after one random dutch dude's youtube
channel obviously they feel like they
have to do this for legal reasons but
come on gilvasunner is not the first
person to upload game music he didn't
own to youtube and he is definitely not
going to be the last at least not while
companies like nintendo are being weird
holdouts about getting their music onto
platforms people actually use what are
they gonna do keep sending thousands of
copyright strikes to random youtube
channels anytime a new one pops up this
channel wasn't gilva center's livelihood
i can't imagine he made any money off of
it at all but i bet the reason he kept
it running for over a decade was because
he and anybody who ever ended up on his
channel after searching for a random
song
loved listening to video game music so
this is just gonna keep happening either
until they finally kill the old youtube
and break people's love for video game
music or until companies like nintendo
wake up realize it's 2022 and start
uploading things themselves
[Music]
ludwig does 31 million so that's not it
holy [ __ ]
yeah the my i stand on the stool and it
just gave out under me
oh my god that was terrifying
yeah i am fine i think this stool has
maybe served
its purpose in life
[Music]